Muy buenas tardes Pues por ahora el
gobierno francés junto con el gobierno
ucraniano están sobre todo evaluando
Cuál sería la relación entre costo
beneficio de entregarle algunos de esos
hay que saber que estos blindados pesan
más de 50 toneladas y que necesitan un
apoyo logístico importante cuando se
esté hablando de abastecimiento de
municiones de combustible y sobre todo
de mantenimiento que es bastante
complejo esto se suma que Francia tan
solo dispone de 226 unidades de estos
tanques y solamente el 60% podría ser
movilizado así que estas son un poco los
puntos que están viendo de un lado y de
otro esto se suma que estos tanques
dejaron de ser producidos por nexter la
empresa francesa desde hace 15 años Así
que también podría haber un problema
cuando se trate de cambiar algún
repuesto de tener repuestos En todo caso
disponibles de este de este tipo de de
tanques por eso alguna manera pues son
los leopar los que podrían ser un poco
más útiles para los ucranianos en vista
de que hay unas dos mil unidades
todo Europa hay que saber que ya poco a
poco pues también hay varios
parlamentarios que piden se haga un
debate en cuanto a saber si Francia debe
o no entregar este tipo de de tanques y
de armamentos a Ucrania y por otra parte
también hemos sabido que Ucrania lo que
ha pedido sobre todo a Francia mucho más
que el uso del pues son también son
camiones de artillería que también
podrían ayudarles ya en el terreno de
batalla